if you could be any character I mean
including yourselves which one would you
be in real life like if you had to be in
Game of Thrones which one would you
choose to be I'd like to be a warg I'd
like to I'd like to like put myself into
them into a wolf
[Applause]
we should just stop
hey everybody its charlie everyone
rejoice we found out that ghost is
confirmed to be coming back during
season 8 from the visual effects
supervisor
so I'll read his quote and he says he
does a lot of stuff so I broke this up
like a top 10 list if only they had
known what they would be doing with
season 8 way back when kid Harrington
was doing this interview he would be way
more excited so I will address star
children as wargs besides brand because
through their start DNA they do have the
genetic predisposition to be able to do
that I'm doing a giveaway for the
Targaryen book that George our Martin is
releasing in November all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video so Joe Bauer the
visual effects supervisor on Game of
Thrones said oh you'll see him again
talking about ghosts he has a fair
amount of screen time in season eight
meaning that he has a lot relatively
compared to previous scenes that they've
used in foriegn earlier seasons he says
he does show up he's very present and
does some pretty cool things so already
everybody's freaking out like okay
they're just some clear moments that
they have to include him in including
the big battles as well as some of the
funnier moments when everyone's having
their reunions at Winterfell
so the big reason why he wasn't around
during season seven is is because they
did shoot a scene with him when Jon went
to meet with Daenerys initially they
shot a goodbye scene but they just left
it on the cutting room floor even though
the season 7 episodes were longer than
normal episodes they just felt like they
wanted to move things along so it was
kind of unfortunate well he doesn't say
it his comment does imply the ghost will
survive till at least the final episode
I think obviously we expect that Jon
Snow if he's going to die would not die
til the final episode ghost and Jon are
thoroughly lengthe matically so they
would not die without each other
so starting with number 10 first would
be his reunion with Jon when he first
returns with Daenerys paying off that
scene that they left on the cutting room
floor during season 7 number 9 a little
bit more important meeting Daenerys for
the first time in a mirror of the scene
where Jon met drogon for the first time
says Jon has this low level mental
connection with ghost ghost would
probably understand who Daenerys is and
what she means to Jon direwolves even
regular wolves are very standoffish so
she you know she would probably try to
cozy up the same way that he cozied up
to drogon maybe they'll play it for a
little bit of
comedy and she accepts him and that's
the end of it like the direwolves way of
saying that I won't try to bite your
head off the next time you walk close by
number 8 ghost meeting the Dragons for
the first time this may be played for a
little more comedy even though it just
sounds really cool when you talk about
it what would that be like he would
probably just accept them from a
distance but it's not like they're gonna
be pals and be sleeping right next to
each other there's really cool moments
and then there's just taking fanservice
a little too far so try to be a little
realistic with your expectations for
ghosts working with the Dragons so
number 7 ghost reacting badly to some of
the new allies that have come back to
Winterfell like Jaime Lannister like
even though everyone's there to help you
can't expect ghosts to react favorably
to every single person that walks
through the gates Jaime Lannister the
last time he was a Winterfell tried to
kill bran by pushing him out the window
so they'll probably just find a funny
way to pay that off we're even though
he'll have his own reunion with bran and
that'll be suitably awkward and
hilarious they'll probably find some
funny way to pay that off with ghosts to
like just keep ghosts as far away from
Jaime as possible while they're all at
Winterfell
but number 6 a ghost Nymeria reunion
because a lot of people are still
wondering what's happening with Nymeria
because Arya had that big goodbye scene
with her that's not you sort of
acknowledging that Nymeria was living
her best life with her super PAC there
and this is the TV shows version of the
George R Martin book super PAC so when I
say that I mean big Wolf Pack it's meant
to be much much larger than normal one
george RR martin many years ago I think
when I was doing Season four videos or
maybe season five I did a direwolves
video acknowledging some of his comments
and when he would do live readings
people would ask him about Nymeria and
her super PAC because Arya could sense
her running around this was before ari
had had her Bree Union and he said well
you know I wouldn't create something
like that and then not use it later at
the time the implication was is people
assumed he was talking about using
Nymeria super PAC to fight the white
walkers in the night king during the
next big battle that they would have
south of the wall so if the visual
effects supervisor said that they're
going all in on dire wolf scenes it
would just make sense they would pay
that extra money to do Nymeria scenes
when they're due
their big battle but number five of
course ghosts shredding all kinds of
whites during the upcoming Battle of
Winterfell he's not gonna ride the bench
it's gonna be crazy the idea is that
they might destroy Winterfell so anybody
that can swing a sword or has a really
giant mouthful of teeth is gonna be
fighting and then taking off once the
battle is done but number four obviously
we're moving down to King's Landing by
the end of the season for another really
big battle
so ghost survives to the end he would
travel with Jon down to King's Landing
so three ghosts and Jon inside the red
keep like they'd never been inside the
castle walls so it'd just be fun to see
him walking around obviously it's gonna
be crazy but number two even bigger
ghost and Jon in the iron throne room in
the wreckage of the iron throne room
because remember they're slowly bringing
Daenerys as vision from the house of the
undying about so you have to imagine
that this is what it looks like after
the battle is over and she's sort of
looking at this nuclear winter that's
been created because it's actual real
winter and the battle has destroyed most
of the castle but how cool would it be
for them to pay off this promo that they
released ahead of season one with John
sitting on the Iron Throne with ghost
next to him now I don't actually expect
to see them do this scene literally but
imagine a version of this with them just
walking through the iron throne room
with the wreckage in the iron throne
sitting in the distance so it sort of
them acknowledging John is the heir to
the Iron Throne so regardless of whether
or not he actually sits on it you do
have to pay that off at some point but
number one probably the biggest one is
ghost helping kill the night king since
everything seems to be pointing towards
John facing him down with a lot of help
from the Dragons Daenerys the other main
characters no way ghost would allow John
to bench him for something that big if
he were still alive and in battle and
available without more evidence we don't
know that the dire wolves are effective
against white walkers themselves but
they probably could take down White's
pretty effectively so that's probably
how they'll use them especially if
Nymeria super pack shows up strafe the
Horde of whites while the people with
Valyrian steel weapons and dragonglass
try to go at the White Walkers and the
knight King himself and while I don't
expect John to warg ghost during any big
final battle I do think the connection
between them will be much stronger
so while bran might be the only person
worried
anything John will get as close as you
could possibly get without actually him
slipping his consciousness into ghosts
mind I'd like to I'd like to like put
myself into them into a wolf but I think
this answers a lot of big questions that
people had about what was going on with
the dire wolves because in the books the
dire wolves are so important for the
stark children that they prospectively
belonged to so because now the later
seasons have started to focus more and
more on John's story is just really
weird that you don't see ghosts there
for the really big moments he would take
ghosts with him wherever he went so
technically he should have gone to
Dragonstone because we don't really know
what the winds of winter plot is going
to be for John meeting Daenerys we don't
know if he is also going to go to
Dragonstone in the same way but just
general rule of thumb is is where John
goes ghost follows but let me know in
the comments what are your really big
ghost scenes that you want to see during
season eight and what'll happen is is
last year we actually started to see
more and more promos in November the
last big teaser that we got was really
just like a brief scene between John and
Sansa so I think the next time we see a
promo for season 8 it'll actually be
some legit footage so whatever ends up
happening I will totally do videos for
it leave your requests in the comments
below - congratulations Micaiah Mooney
please email me on the about page of my
channel so I can get your details click
here to learn about the season 8 early
release date and click here for that new
excerpt foreshadowing Daenerys story
during season 8 thank you so much for
watching everybody to stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight